hey youtubers is Charlie so everybody's
freaking out about the spider-man
trailer it was supposed to come around
this time in Tom Holland has even said
he might not appear in infinity or so
I'm gonna splaying what's going on it's
not as bad as it sounds it's not that
crazy so most of the time everybody's
freaking out about the trailer like when
is it gonna come when we gotta get that
first spider-man trailer what's probably
gonna happen is is if we don't see it by
the end of the year like guardians of
the galaxy 2 is finally dropping their
trailer around Doctor Strange in Star
Wars rogue one you know two big Disney
films coming really soon if we don't see
spider-man at homecoming by the end of
the year they'll probably just wait till
the Superbowl in February because the
movie is coming out in July like early
July of next year so general rule of
thumb is is that you get like the first
big official trailer like a two and a
half minute plus trailer about six
months out from the movie sometimes
they'll drop a teaser a year before and
for those of you asking like why didn't
they drop a teaser when we were one year
out back in July they kind of did only
it was just for Hall age I did a video
for like explaining the footage in it
but they just perma banned any footage
online so we'll just had a link to that
video at the end of this so you can like
find out a little bit about what was
actually in that footage but they'll
probably rework a version of that for
the first trailer usually the first
trailer is just like hey look at this
it's badass it's gonna be awesome enjoy
when they get a little closer to the
film then they start doing the story
trailers like they did that with the
rogue one trailer I just posted where it
kind of explains the story of the movie
usually the first trailer doesn't do
that it just kind of shows you a bunch
of cool things mixed together but don't
worry that a trailer has not already
dropped there was like a leaked list of
trailers that were gonna drop this year
in there was like an October 15th date
listed for the spider-man homecoming
trailer but that was on a Saturday and
nobody really drops big first trailers
on Saturdays usually Tuesday is the big
day to drop big trailers just don't
worry about it
they just started editing the movie like
they wrapped a little while ago like I
posted a video
John watts the directors been posting
stuff for behind the scenes like hey
look we're doing green-screen today Tom
Holland posts up hey look at these
stunts that I'm working on so they've
been feeding out like really short
behind-the-scenes teasers just like hey
this is what's going on just a quick
update when they get ready to drop an
actual teaser you'll start seeing more
of that stuff so the more you see Marvel
in people with the movie posting stuff
the closer we are to getting actual
footage they usually do they kind of
ramp up and then it's like boom just
drop the bomb on you but just expect
that to be a slightly more polished
version of the comic-con trailer just
something really fun to give you an idea
for the energy of the film while showing
off some of the big characters like
zendaya and everybody thinks that she's
Mary Jane that's still unconfirmed there
was a little bit of a vulture fight
during that Comic Con trailer they'll
probably put that in there too just to
let you know who some of the big
villains are some of the big challenges
but mostly it'll focus on the fun stuff
young Peter Parker in high school also
trying to be spider-man at the same time
would not be surprised if they also try
to work Robert Downey jr. into that
first trailer too just because he is
such a draw for audiences but I'm not
expecting him to wear his armor and any
trailer footage maybe in like the very
last trailer now the other reason people
were freaking out about spider-man stuff
was about Avengers infinity war Tom
Holland was doing an interview recently
where people were asking him about his
involvement with infinity war everybody
expects him to be in it but he said it's
all up in the air like air quotes I
believe some sort of deal is in the mix
but I'm unclear as to what that deal is
so some people interpreted that as him
saying I might not be in the movie but
that's not what's going on at all but
when he auditioned for the role of Peter
Parker spider-man in civil war that was
also kind of an audition for the next
big solo spider-man movie spider-man
homecoming with the idea that would
become a trilogy so naturally you would
expect that the contract he had to sign
had all those movies on it
so if Marvel wants him to be in a movie
they can say you have to be in this
movie and he's contractually obligated
to appear it's the same thing with Tom
Hiddleston any of the other actors that
sign multi-picture
Marvel just builds a standard number of
options into its contracts now there are
certain special cases like with people
like Michael Douglas who is in the
ant-man movie as Hank Pym big character
but he's such an expensive actor and
it's a bit of a stunt casting that they
probably don't sign people like that
two-six picture deals Samuel Jackson to
had a slightly different contract so
don't worry if they want to use Tom
Hollands spider-man in a movie it's not
going to be an issue typically like when
people say they're working the deal out
it's really just like the little stuff
like do the directors actually want to
use him is their version of the script
that does not include the character like
there was an early draft of Captain
America civil war that had Carol Danvers
in it that got thrown out early on just
because of like there's way too much
stuff happening in this movie we need to
focus on the core characters more so
just general rule of thumb is is that
they're gonna start focusing on these
new characters more so you have Doctor
Strange spider-man Captain Marvel Black
Panther they'll always have the core
Avengers characters in there like I
think they'll all resign their contracts
and do Robert Downey jr. type things
where maybe they don't always get new
trilogies or do new solo films but they
appear in other people's films but
doubling down on the new characters
you'll just see them all over Marvel
phase 3 phase 4 but here's my big
question for you guys which other Marvel
movies besides the spider-man movies
obviously in the Avengers films do you
think we'll see Peter Parker show up in
I'm not expecting him in Doctor Strange
that's like the next Marvel movie that's
coming we do kind of know what the
post-credits scenes are going to be I'll
do a video for that later because it's a
little bit spoilery but it's still kind
of speculative because a lot of people
haven't seen the movie yet but it seems
like it's mostly going to be Thor
centric just teasing Thor Ragnarok stuff
that's happening but there is a Thor
Ragnarok video I was originally gonna do
till he announced all this Tom Hollands
stuff so that video will post next I'll
talk about some Luke Cage at the end of
that it was a great series that I felt
like lost some steam towards the end so
it wasn't quite as much fun as daredevil
season 2 and the storytelling wasn't
quite as good as Jessica Jones but
overall it was a great series I just
didn't like it as much as I liked some
of the other series so a new thor
ragnarok new Doctor Strange posting sued
the
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a whole bunch of DC stuff
happening to I explained that in the
last big Wonder Woman trailer I just
posted so watch that that'll give you an
idea for some of the DC stuff that's
happening next week well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch the Iron Fist trailer again and
you can click here to learn about the
ant-man Easter Egg that's going on with
Doctor Strange thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight